welcome to another edition of famous
Friday where I look at famous
entrepreneurs and how you can model
their success to cheap success of your
own today's lesson is take your shot too
many entrepreneurs you know you have
this idea you see an opportunity in
front of you and you don't take your
shot you think I'm not ready yet I'm not
good enough yet the competition is too
strong I can't do it i don't i don't
have enough money i don't have enough
resources to go for it yet and so you
don't one of my favorite stores is of
Jim Henson who created the Muppets and
created the characters behind Sesame
Street and sold his company the Walt
Disney for two hundred million dollars
became the most successful puppeteer of
all time following his passion and it
started when he was in high school and
he had an interest in puppets and a
local TV show put out a call saying hey
we need a puppeteer to come on board and
help us with one of our programs and
there were so many reasons why Jim
Henson could have said I'm not ready for
that you know he could have said I'm in
high school he could have said this way
better puppeteers out there than I am he
could have said I don't have enough
money to make a real puppet I don't even
have a real puppet that going demo with
there's so many reasons why I wouldn't
work that so many reasons for him to
tell himself that he's not ready yet to
not take that shot yet and yet what did
he do he took his mom's old green coat
cut it up put two ping pong balls on it
and went to audition he took his shot he
said what's the worst is gonna happen
they say no but he got that job and he
got another job after and another job
after and another job after and
continued to snowball and build momentum
for him but all because it started it
started small excited with that one act
of taking his shot
even when all the odds were stacked
against him so if you've got an
opportunity in front of you and you're
telling yourself all the reasons why
won't work out just take your shot
because remember as Wayne Gretzky said
you miss one hundred percent of the
shots that you never take believe if you
guys like this video you want to see
more likely more like it subscribe to
the channel I'll see you soon